what's going on guys this is rob let's
talk about miss marvel episode one we
will do an easter eggs video uh honestly
we're gonna do a lot of easter egg
videos this week because we got the
black adam trailer that comes out and
then there's the obi-wan kenobi episode
that we have to talk about then we have
talked about last week's episode because
i was in new york at the time we got a
lot of stuff we got to talk about so
there will be a video on the easter eggs
and everything that comes out later but
let's just talk about the first episode
here right initial thoughts whatever you
want to call it so this first episode
was amazing absolutely loved it one of
the things that i will say right off the
bat the powers of kamala khan i'm glad
they didn't make her an inhuman one
because the inhumans suck and two
because it's just it's a great deviation
right it's a great way to kind of break
away i know a lot of people are going to
kind of be like well her powers need to
be able to stretch in her identity all
that kind of stuff i never looked at it
that way right i never looked at like
the powers of miss marvel somehow being
tied directly into like her identity and
all that kind of stuff instead the story
told or at least the comics by g willa
wilson told two separate stories the
first one was like the story of her life
as a superhero the second part of the
story probably the more significant
story if you're looking for character
development is her struggle as a
pakistani american living in new jersey
dealing with like super traditional
parents and like trying to be a what is
by all standards of measurement a modern
american girl right so like trying to to
find some sort of
normalcy right some normal between those
two different lifestyles so i don't mind
that they change their powers right it
was never a huge deal to me never got
pissed off about it i was like is this
whatever right i mean it's cool plus if
they did give her the ability to stretch
people who don't know anything about
comic books would be like so is she
related to like reed richards is she
like the daughter of reed or something
like that it'd probably confuse people a
little bit or something on those lines
so having said that i do love the the
whole ambiance and the feel of this show
because there's so many things they just
nailed from the comic books so many
things they nailed that i absolutely
loved so first things first the family
dynamic that was always the the one of
the more interesting points when it came
to miss marvel right like literally as
we just said this idea that our parents
are super traditional her mom is really
a dick most of the time she's always
like i know you want to go and have fun
but no you can't do that right you have
to do things that are unfun because i'm
your mom and i told you to and i can't
adapt to the modern era so the result of
this is that you have this this whole
this whole kind of dichotomy where she's
trying to fit in she's trying to find
her place in the world and not really
sure where she fits in and in a lot of
ways in the comics she doesn't fit in i
mean she's got nakia she's got bruno i
think it's nokia is how you pronounce
her name but she's she's got both of her
friends but quite literally they nailed
it perfectly right like what is high
school if not a whole bunch of socially
awkward teenagers walking around
pretending like they have it figured out
right so it's a really really cool
concept absolutely loved the way they
handled that again the family dynamic
was great and i loved that they kind of
tugged at the heartstrings right i
thought it was adorable when like her
her mom was like no you can't go to
avengers con or whatever it is and then
ultimately because her brother kind of
talks to talks to the parents they kind
of change their mind and like her dad
comes busting in and like an incredible
hulk outfit i was like i mean if that
were me i would have been like yeah man
let's go do that that sounds amazing
of course kamala and one of the cool
things about her character is she
oftentimes just screws up i mean she's a
teenager right like what is she if not a
person that just makes mistakes all the
time right that's literally what
teenagers do right it's a learning thing
and so i loved i loved that whole thing
where she just kind of really just
crushed your dad i don't love that you
question your dad but i love the idea
that like
she is a teenager doing teenage things
and screwing up the way that a teenager
does one of the things that i didn't
want to see in this is that she's like
the teenager who's trying to figure it
out yet somehow makes all the right
choices you know what i mean like nobody
wants to see that it's just it's not
realistic it's not relatable in any any
real way i loved how they did it there
one of the things that i actually liked
the way they handled it just because the
fact that we wouldn't really get the
comic book carryover that we're used to
is the potential romantic interest of
kamala khan in the comics kamala khan
has a crush on a couple different people
well romantic interest in a couple of a
couple different people first one is sam
alexander who's amazing the second one
is miles morales neither of which exists
in the marvel cinematic universe as it
stands right now miles morales may
appear somewhere along the line because
of the events of into the spider-verse
there may be some crossover we don't
really know yet we won't know until it
happens or is confirmed by feige or
somebody like that and sam alexander we
haven't seen hide nor hair of him right
so obviously we're not going to get that
the idea of bruno and kamala khan
honestly i always kind of felt like they
should be like a romantic couple at
least in initially like this should have
happened pretty fast but it also made
sense that they were just really really
good friends and so again it could sort
of go either way regardless of the
situation i'm not too upset about the
way it's happening i actually really
really like it the next thing is again
one of the things that i love the most
about this is it really is a teenager
show looking at this show you can tell
the target audience is largely younger
girls right as largely girls in high
school things like that who are looking
for a bit of relatability in the marvel
cinematic universe where they can't
normally find it no problem with that
for me i love reading about teenagers in
comic books and the reason for that is
because if you go and you read like a
captain america story captain america is
cool right he's interesting he does some
cool stuff but for the most part he's
usually super serious right he's not
really the comedic type thor is kind of
sometimes tony stark's just a dick but i
mean you don't really get a whole lot of
like comedic tones insofar as like it's
fun goofy that kind of thing and the
teenage stories while it's not
necessarily goofy marvel does a really
really good job of capturing the coming
of age element right where you literally
have a team called the champions for
example so you've got kamala khan you've
got sam alexander you've got miles
morales you've got viv the daughter of
vision and you got a couple others one
or two others i can't remember who the
other ones are but you have a you have a
teenage group of superheroes operating
as a team and so they're falling in love
out of love there's love triangles going
on there's well i really like him but i
also really like him and i don't know
which one i like more and all that kind
of stuff and as an adult you look at
that and it is kind of silly but at the
same time it's just kind of the the
youthful vibrance that goes into it
right the youthful idea of just kids out
there having fun being superheroes and
that i think really was captured
incredibly well in this and i'm excited
to see where they go because literally
the end of the episode her mom is of
course chastising her for going out and
having a good time i would have done the
same thing whatever if her mom was like
why did you sneak out is that because
all you ever do is say no right so i
figured i might as well assume you said
yes and just go do it right just go have
some fun i'll pay the price easier to
seek forgiveness than permission so the
result of that is of course you saw her
out there having a great time and of
course when she got back and her mom
asked her you know do you want to be
some girl who's good like we raised you
to be who's probably going to grow up to
be boring as hell or do you want to be
like some cosmic girl with their heads
in the head in the clouds and she's like
i want to be cosmic
well i love that element and i'm hoping
that kind of continues on when her and
bruno are like making the plan and all
that kind of stuff you know it's not
going to work right none of it's gonna
go according to plan even though it
would have been awesome to pull like
some starsky and hutch stuff and just
like ride a bicycle off a bridge onto a
bus that would have been amazing
but you knew none of that was gonna
happen but i loved all those different
elements that all just kind of came
together and combined together into this
now there are some other great little
easter eggs some of which i'll talk
about that we'll talk about here we'll
reiterate in our easter eggs video but
one of the things that i really really
loved is that they gave us an
explanation as to how it is
everybody knows about avengers in-game
because it's the question that we never
got an answer to we never got an answer
to the question how does the world know
about avengers in-game the world knows
that tony stark died but we don't know
how they know he died we don't know how
they know about thanos and the infinity
stones and all that kind of stuff you
know we didn't know if it was one of
those things where like everything ended
and then like the avengers just went on
tv and held a press conference right we
didn't know what went on come to find
out scotland's got a podcast which i
would really love to see
not gonna lie i would love a paul rudd
scott lang podcast
[Laughter]
where he's like interviewing other
members of the cast of like the marvel
cinematic universe and they're all
basically in character i would love that
right it would be absolutely amazing it
doesn't even have to be like an ongoing
thing make it like a 10 episode mini
series right just uh just a mini podcast
right that's it right you know it's 10
episodes each one's an hour long when
you're done you're done and that's
that's it that's that's all we get it'd
just be a great little thing i think
honestly i think people would eat it up
to be honest with you i think it'd be
one of the most one of the most viral
podcasts out there but literally scott
lang like doing interviews and talking
to people that's basically how the world
found out about the events of avengers
end game and i think it's a cool thing
because a podcast sounds exactly like
something like scott lang would do right
like now i would hope that he would have
what's his name along for the ride where
he could basically give us like a
synopsis what was it what was it was it
luis was that the guy the guy that
everybody wants to basically open for
like deadpool 3 to basically give us the
synopsis of like how deadpool ended up
in the fox universe or the current
universe that guy i mean i would hope
he'd be there
but regardless right i love that they
gave us that little easter egg and there
were a bunch of them too right there
were a bunch of other ones that went
into it for example when you go through
and you have like all those different
depictions of kamala khan when she's
talking about like miss marvel carol
danvers some of them are like her old
school version right from like way back
in the 70s when she first appeared some
of them are actually when moon star
became uh took the miss marvel moniker
for a while that was actually uh the
outfit that um zoe was wearing so again
like cool little easter eggs and little
tidbits that go into it definitely dug
all that and i would say above all else
the thing that's the most important here
and the thing that i loved the most
about all this
is the fact that they captured the very
nature of kamala khan which is she's a
fan girl she's literally a girl who just
loves superheroes absolutely loves
superheroes and she loves carol danvers
more than anybody else now as soon as
they opened up with that and they
confirmed that was gonna happen she's
just like praising she's right like the
sun rises and sets on carol danvers as
far as miss marvel is concerned right
won't hear a word against her as soon as
they open that up i was like oh dude man
like people who hate who hate carol
danvers they're gonna be pissed right i
don't know a part of me was just kind of
like hey everybody who hates carol
danvers
eat it like i absolutely loved that
i thought it was funny so it's going to
be nice to see them uh just just kind of
sitting stewing being pissed off i can't
wait to read their angry tweets but the
thing about this is i love that because
that's the central point of her
character right in the first story arc
one of the things to know in the first
story arc of g willow wilson's run on
miss marvel when she was initially
exposed to the terrigen mist because
marvel stupidly thought it was an idea
to make her into an inhuman which sucked
because he and human sucked but uh when
when that that whole story arc basically
completed right when she got her powers
and all that kind of stuff she basically
ends up meeting carol danvers and carol
danvers essentially kind of gives her
her blessing and says like go forward
and do your thing right like go be a
superhero just understand you're
stepping into a pretty significant role
here and what you're doing is no small
thing so when you go out there in the
world and you act as a superhero you
reflect all of us so if you start
screwing up we're gonna bring the hammer
down
right it was a cool thing she got to
literally meet her idol so again i i i
loved the first episode i really really
enjoyed the first episode of course
again kind of circling back to her
powers for a bit and i think this is
something worth discussing here
the nature of her powers
really seems to be strongly tied to the
idea of like the ten rings right like
the whole idea of the mandarin and all
that kind of stuff because the way her
energy emanates looks almost exactly the
way the energy emanates from the ten
rings now i don't know if anybody at
marvel has come out and explicitly said
no the two powers are not linked they
have nothing to do with each other i'm
not entirely sure i have no real idea i
know another popular theory and really
the way her powers uh emanated as well
right the way they manifest it looks a
lot like eternal technology so that's
entirely possible as well right we know
fostos was like the the the weapons guy
right he was the one that like built
arms and armament different things like
that it's not that far beyond the realm
of imagination to believe that when you
basically had the warring societies that
started destroying each other and led to
the eternals essentially staying hands
off that some of their technology just
kind of got left behind right was
basically sort of stuck around there and
that so you know it made its way from
one person to the next and that was
really it right i mean the idea of them
sharing their technology with humanity
even if only on a limited scale that was
kind of a main focal point of the
eternals granted we don't know the full
extent of the powers of kamala khan but
given the way in which her powers
manifested i i still stick by the idea
this is the marvel cinematic universe's
version of either the quantum bands or
the mega bands or the two of them tied
together i still say that's most likely
what this is going to be i don't know if
we're really going to see like a quasar
wendell vaughn or philavelle or genus
fell or any of those guys we may not i
think this is kind of what we get in
terms of the mega bands quantum bands
that sort of thing but we won't really
know right i mean all we really know
right now and we'll probably find i mean
we'll find out by the end of the end of
the show but within the next couple
episodes i think we'll get a better
understanding especially because of the
mid credit scene that we got which was
damage control basically saying okay
grab that girl and bring her in and
let's find out what's going on here
right so again i'm really excited about
the show absolutely loved it i thought
it was phenomenal a great episode uh so
yeah i'm definitely gonna stick with it
really hyped about it let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching i
will catch you all later
peace